[Musique]
je peux vous dire qu'en 74 la tour noté
c'était à gagner chanté par mon père
patrick z est effectivement c'était en
1974 que la chanson est sortie au québec
les gens c'est drôle parce que parfois
vous remettrez pour me dire mais qu'est
ce que ton père a consommé à l'époque où
il chantait agadou faut comprendre que
mon père ne pas écrit la chanson i les
interprètes au québec
bien
[Musique]
il a enregistré en 73 en fait il a
découvert en 73 lors d'un voyage en
martinique et il a enregistré et c'est
un grand succès qui lui colle encore à
la peau enfin sa part exane est
automatiquement à penser mais qui a
composé un gain agadou c'est une femme
et un homme qui ont composé les paroles
millas maire et michel de l'encré c'est
une chanson du folklore
elle s'est alors c'est une chanson qui
raconte l'histoire je sais pas si vous
avez déjà écouter les paroles l'os et
c'est très joyeux quand on regarde la
danse mais c'est l'histoire d'un gars
qui va en prison parce que toucher au
fruit défendu
[Musique]
en travaillant sur la biographie de mon
père j'ai découvert entre autres
combien environ il y avait deux copies
de gadio qui ont été vendues on est
autour de 500 mille ans ne pas les
chiffres exacts mais ce que j'ai appris
aussi c'est que sont l'enregistrement la
chanson il ya une petite voix derrière
donc ce qu'on appelle un back vocals et
c'est la voix de rené angélil la voix
très perché la voix très aiguë vous
allez entendre lorsque vous allez
réécouter la gadoue et bien croyez le ou
non
c'est rené angelil qui meurent à ce que
c'est quoi la colère et la chorégraphie
est très simple a alors agadou dou dou
post la nana et moules café tap la pomme
pape la poire post la nana et moules
café
[Musique]
comment qui va par exemple le jour mon
père va bien dans les circonstances
c'est mon père qui va avoir 80 lots mois
de descendre mon père qu'il parkinson
depuis un bon bout de temps il va bien
je voudrais dans ces circonstances c'est
sûr que c'est une maladie qui est
dégénérative qui atteint beaucoup sa
qualité de vie mais mon père au niveau
moteur défensif difficile mais je peux
vous dire qu'au niveau cérébral et les
tout là alors agadou dou dou pawson m au
café pâtes pommes daf le pressman café
[Musique]
ap